two neutron stars caught in a death
spiral
this massive kilanova explosion not only
sheds light on the creation of heavy
elements such as gold and platinum
it also provides scientists with unique
insight into one of the most mysterious
objects in the universe
challenges are imagination it also
challenges our theoretical physics we
have to go to our computer models our
mathematics to have some estimate of
what this might be like
[Music]
now scientists don't have to rely on
their imaginations
they can use hard data from the kill
Anova
to work out what makes neutron stars
tick
there's so much information we got from
observing that one single event that one
colliding neutron star pair now for the
first time we have an accurate estimate
of the mass of the neutron star and the
diameter we can finally begin to piece
together how neutron stars really work
they calculate the diameter is just 12.4
miles
one mile less than the length of
Manhattan
nailing down any physical characteristic
is really important and if there's going
to be one the radius is a big one
because from there if you know the mass
you can get the density if you know that
overall density you can start to figure
out what the layering inside of a
neutron star is like
for physicists the interior of a neutron
star is one of the most intriguing
places in the universe
you have to realize that the conditions
inside a neutron star are very very
different than the conditions that exist
here on Earth we're talking about
material that's so dense that even the
the nuclei of atoms can't hold together
with the neutron star you're taking
something that weighs more than the Sun
and compressing it down to be smaller
than a city it's so dense that if you
try to put it on the ground it would
fall right through the Earth
[Music]
high density means high gravity gravity
200 billion times greater than on Earth
magic climbing up on a table on the
surface of a neutron star and jumping
off you're going to just get flattened
instantly and just spray it out on that
surface so don't even think about trying
to do push-ups
added to the intense gravity are hugely
powerful magnetic fields awesome x-ray
radiation electric Fields 30 million
times more powerful than lightning bolts
and blizzards of high energy particles
for a space traveler this is not a good
neighborhood
[Music]
to find yourself in the vicinity of a
neutron star it's going to be bad news
first you would be torn apart by the
incredibly strong magnetic fields then
the X-ray radiation would blast you to a
crisp and as it pulled you closer its
intense gravity would stretch out your
atoms and molecules into a long thin
stream you would build your speed faster
and faster and you would finally impact
the surface
splatter across it and that process
would release as much energy as a
nuclear bomb
between falling into a neutron star
versus a black hole I think I'd pick the
black hole because I don't really feel
like being torn apart by a magnetic
field and blasted with x-rays foreign
scale neutron stars may be pint-sized
but they sure pack a serious punch
secret to all this pent-up power is
what's going on below the surface
armed with the new kill Anova data we
can now take a virtual Journey Into the
Heart of a neutron star first we must
pass through its atmosphere
now it's not like the Earth's atmosphere
which goes up like a hundred miles on a
neutron star the atmosphere is about
this deep and it's extremely dense
compared to the air around us
below the compressed atmosphere is a
crust of ionized iron a mixture of
Crystal iron nuclei and free-flowing
iron electrons now the gravity is so
strong that it's almost perfectly smooth
the biggest mountains on the surface are
going to be less than a quarter of an
inch high a quarter inch mountain range
may sound odd
what's wrong
things get even stranger as we go below
the surface
this is home to the strongest material
in the universe
it's so weird scientists liken it to
nuclear pasta
as we dive beneath the crust of a
neutron star the neutrons themselves
start to glue themselves together into
exotic shapes first they form clumps
that look something like gnocchi then
deeper the gnocchi glue themselves
together to form long strands that look
like spaghetti even deeper the spaghetti
fused together to form sheets of lasagna
and then finally the lasagna fused
together to become a uniform mess but
with holes in it
so it looks like pennant
this is pasta nuclear style simmering at
a temperature of over a million degrees
Fahrenheit extreme gravity bends
squeezes stretches and buckles neutrons
creating a material 100
000 billion times denser than iron but
the journey gets even more extreme
even deeper is more mysterious and
harder to understand the core of a
neutron star which is very far away from
these layers which we call the nuclear
pasta is perhaps the most exotic form of
matter so exotic it might be the last
Bastion of matter before complete
gravitational collapse into a black hole
data from NASA's Chandra Observatory
suggests the core is made up of a
superfluid a bizarre friction-freeze
state of matter
superfluids produced in the lab exhibits
strange properties such as the ability
to flow upwards and Escape air-type
containers
Although our knowledge of the star's
interior is still hazy there's no
mystery about its dazzling birth
forged into life during the most
spectacular event the universe has to
offer the explosive death of a massive
star
neutron stars spark into life amid the
death of their parents
stuff their the
story of Resurrection or life from Death
it's all part of a cosmic cycle
Stars Are Born from giant clouds of very
cold gas those clouds collapse under
their own gravity and the density of the
core at the center of that collapse
starts to increase
[Music]
a star is a huge nuclear fusion reactor
the force of its gravity is so powerful
that it fuses atoms together to make
progressively heavier and heavier
elements
the star fuses hydrogen into helium once
it exhausts its hydrogen then if it's
massive enough it can start fusing
helium at its core
Fusion continues forming carbon
oxygen nitrogen
all the way up to iron
once the star has iron in the core it's
almost like you've poisoned it because
this extinguishes the nuclear reactions
in the core of the star you fuse
something into iron and you get no
energy all of a sudden there's nothing
to support the crush of gravity no
radiation pressure pushing out means no
pressure keeping the outer regions from
falling in and that's what they do as
the star collapses in its Death Rows its
core becomes the wildest craziest and
freakiest pressure cooker in the whole
universe
ingredients are all in place time to
start cooking up a neutron star
thank you